hello my name is mark sheets I direct
the pharmaco metric center of excellence
at Midwestern university and practice
clinically at Northwestern medicine as
an infectious diseases pharmacist
I want to thank lab roots today for the
opportunity to talk to you to talk about
a subject I'm very passionate about and
it's really trying to make vancomycin
safer for our patients so today we'll
talk about vancomycin how the urinary
biomarkers and precision dosing might
really fulfill this hope of precision
medicine for what is the currently the
most frequently utilized antibiotic in
the hospital setting the objectives for
today's talk are to describe the
exposure response relationships that
exist for vancomycin you just set my
timer here that exists for vancomycin
and discuss kidney injury we will also
talk about some of these newer
biomarkers that may prove useful in the
clinical setting and really how we might
eventually start to apply these
biomarkers to make dosing safer for our
patients so vancomycin why are we
talking about vancomycin this is an
antibiotic that was approved in 1958
so by antibiotic standards this is one
of our older antibiotics
it is a tri cyclic glycosylated peptide
antibiotic and it was isolated in the
jungles of Borneo came from a soil
sample that Eli Lilly had sent
scientists out to collect these soil
samples and really try to find some
fermented products that were active
against pathogens at the time and it was
very highly active against gram-positive
pathogens that had activity against
almost all staphylococcal pathogens and
the name vancomycin was actually for
vanquish it was able to vanquish just
about every staphylococcal pathogen that
they could find and it has activity
against some Enterococcus species as
well
now let's say the bike binds to the
Diala d-alanine cell wall precursor and
that in turn prevents bacterial cell
wall synthesis so this is what we call a
slowly Seidel antibiotic by inhibiting
the cell wall it is able to kill these
bacteria slowly over time and today
vancomycin really is the most frequently
utilized antibiotic in the hospital
setting if you look at the numbers
there's probably over three million
people that receive vancomycin annually
and that's in the United States alone so
this is an antibiotic that is seeing
quite a bit of use and many of our
patients are receiving it therefore in
addition to making sure that's an
efficacious medication we should also
make sure that it is being delivered in
a safe of a manner as possible well we
talked about vancomycin we talked about
a couple of major toxicities now the
older data really had had found that
there was some Auto toxicity and some
neurotoxicity associated with vancomycin
in today's practice it is possible for
that to occur but we usually see much
less of that at the within the
therapeutic window of of vancomycin
today essentially how much vancomycin
we're giving today we see much less
ototoxicity and neurotoxicity we're
going to spend most of our time today
talking about nephrotoxicity and that's
because nephrotoxicity is a very common
event for patients that receive
vancomycin acute acute kidney injury is
a major concern these days and the
reason is because in many hospitalized
patients especially among the critically
ill it's a common occurrence and it can
lead to prolonged morbidity and
mortality so what happens in the
hospital has very long effects for the
patient whether or not they leave the
hospital and if they leave the hospital
their quality of life after after
leaving vancomycin
an approximate attributable rate of
about 10% of acute kidney injury
compared to other active antimicrobials
against gram-positive agents and I will
show you some of that data so let's
first and start by taking a bit of a
historic view if we look at vancomycin
over the years this is a PubMed search
that was conducted between the years
1977 and truncated at the end of last
years at the end of 2019 and if we look
just for the report of vancomycin and
kidney injury we can see that between
1977 and 2019 it was relatively flat up
until a period of time and that period
of time probably corresponds with when
the pneumonia guidelines came out in
2005 the pneumonia guidelines came out
and recommended that for some of our
hospital acquired pneumonia we might
consider increasing the vancomycin
exposures such that the minimal
concentration the trough concentrations
would range between 15 and 20 micrograms
per mil in 2009 the vancomycin
guidelines came out and these were the
first guidelines to address how we
should be dosing vancomycin for a
variety of infections and you can
already see that there was an uptick in
kidney injury by that time so the
pneumonia guidelines probably set the
wheel in motion and the vancomycin
guidelines really sort of reciprocated
that perhaps we might want to increase
the exposures for vancomycin and you can
see that either by publication bias or
by real event we started to note much
more kidney injury in the literature
that was deemed associated with thangka
mice now these data were only up until
1977 so I'll show you some of the
earlier data before
so vancomycin again was FDA approved in
1958 and it was very quickly shelved and
the reason was very quickly shelved is
because this was a fermentation product
and when it initially came out Eli Lilly
was asked to bring it to market very
very quickly and they did so and the
reason they did so was because there
were really no other antibiotics at the
time that had this type of activity
against Staphylococcus aureus and it was
a very messy product it was a very dirty
product you can see on the far left
picture there it really was not a clean
and purified product over time they were
able to purify the product but what
happened was that methicillin came out
and the other anti staphylococcal
penicillins came out shortly after
vancomycin and vancomycin was shelved
because it was the more toxic of the
antibiotics and i'll show you when the
uptake happened again
so when vancomycin first came out so in
the 1950s and early 1960s we saw this
pyrogen reaction these were thought to
be reactions that were secondary to the
unpurified product and some of these
very early studies were excellent you
can see in in 1962 there was a report
that in patients with azo tamiya or
renal insufficiency vancomycin
vancomycin should be used with caution
and the therapy should be guided by
repeated serum assays so back in 1962
they were really promoting the use of
vancomycin very similar to the way that
it's being promoted today they said that
if patients were young and healthy they
did not think that you would have to do
assays to monitor the concentrations of
vancomycin except in unusual
circumstances and this early product
caused a bunch of phlebitis and a bunch
of nephrotoxicity but it was all thought
really to be due to the impurities as
time progressed and
we started to see methicillin resistance
then vancomycin you started to occur
much more frequently it was the it
became the drug of choice for
methicillin-resistant staphylococcus
aureus and by the time that this
happened around the 1980s vancomycin was
a very pure and pyrogen free product
nephrotoxicity was occurring in
approximately about five percent of
patients however if you gave concomitant
nephrotoxic that rate could go up by
thirty percent to about thirty five
percent so really people viewed
vancomycin as a product that was really
safe from a kidney perspective there
were early animal studies such as this
rat study where they gave up to four
hundred milligrams per kilogram which is
an ala metrically scale dose that is a
little bit higher than what we would
give our patients on a regular basis
today and they found absolutely no
kidney damage with this now later when
they performed necropsy they were able
to find that much of the vancomycin was
probably had probably crystallized
within the intraperitoneal injection
sorry the subcutaneous injection so a
lot of the vancomycin was not absorbed
so some of these some of these studies
that happened very early that found very
little renal toxicity may be confounded
by the fact that the dose was just not
absorbed there was some dog data that
was able to show that in dogs if you had
given them a high dose they they did end
up in in renal failure and when rats
were given doses vancomycin and means
other than subcutaneous injection they
also saw Nefera toxicity and then almost
brings us up to the present day in 2009
those vancomycin guideline
came out and they recommended that
vancomycin should be monitored for
patients receiving prolonged therapy and
that for for serious infections patients
could receive exposures that resulted in
troughs between 15 and 20 milligrams per
liter
that's micrograms per milliliter and if
patients had more than two consecutive
instances of serum creatinine over fifty
percent increase from baseline they
would call that nephrotoxicity so the
new guidelines ask clinicians to start
dosing patients with higher exposures of
vancomycin but it also realized that
they didn't know what would happen from
a nephrotoxicity standpoint and they
created a definition for nephrotoxicity
and asked clinicians and researchers to
use that when considering whether or not
a patient became nephrotoxic and after
those guidelines came out many studies
able to show a dose toxicity response
relationship that is when patients
achieve trough concentrations less than
10 they had much lower nephrotoxicity
than when they achieved concentrations
that exceeded 20 milligrams per liter
now it was important that these studies
also were finding that patients that had
received trough concentrations between
15 and 20 in retrospective analysis were
performing better from an efficacy
standpoint that is the higher dose of
vancomycin while it was more nephrotoxic
and causing more kidney injury also was
more efficacious but it was notable that
we were seeing more nephrotoxicity we've
developed a good number of
classification schemes for kidney injury
some of the most commonly used today
our the a kan the rifle and the que digo
classification schemes the ones that are
being used most frequently today
generally use a serum creatinine rise of
one and a half times baseline that's
shown in stage one for a ki N and K do
and that is or a 0.3 milligram per
deciliter increase in serum creatinine
and we'll show you some data about why
that number is used as opposed to the
number of 0.5 or 50% increase from the
vancomycin guidelines we really did not
have many prospective studies with
vancomycin where you could clearly
compare vancomycin use to a relevant
comparator and assess nephrotoxicity in
2012 richard wonder inc when my
colleagues at Northwestern published
this paper in clinical infectious
diseases this study the Zephyr study
took five and a half years to complete
they randomized over 1200 patients to
get under 400 patients a valuable and
the per protocol analysis now the groups
are relatively similar and we could
spend the better part of a half an hour
discussing this study alone but
important in this study it was a
randomized study and they allowed
pharmacists to adjust the doses of
vancomycin to desired trough
concentrations in this study they saw a
nephrotoxicity rate of 18.2% for
vancomycin patients in about eight point
four percent for lynnae's live patients
in my mind this is some of the best
evidence of the attributable rate of
vancomycin toxicity because it comes
from a prospective study now the rates
are going to vary considerably based on
a patient's comorbidities but this gives
us a pretty good a pretty good estimate
of what nephrotoxicity might look like
in in a comparative analysis of
affected patients now prior to 2009 it
was thought that vancomycin caused
nephrotoxicity primarily through an
interstitial nephritis mechanism so more
of an allergic type picture causing
causing kidney injury and this was
really a rare event in an event that was
very difficult to predict that some
patients just seem to have this more
allergic picture to vancomycin as the
doses started to become increased it
became increasingly recognized that
higher doses caused acute tubular
necrosis with vancomycin and this was
indeed dose responsive I still remember
the day I received a call from one of my
nephrology colleagues and she said mark
I have a have a case series of people
that have acute tubular necrosis from
vancomycin and I I said I don't know if
I believe that
vancomycin causes acute interstitial
nephritis and it really isn't very much
of a nephrotoxic well over time we've
now found that vancomycin really does
cause acute tubular necrosis that is the
dose responsive mechanism for toxicity
and that model is can be recapitulated
in the animals so in a rat model we have
also seen that as you increase the dose
of ANCA myosin you do indeed get
proximal tubular necrosis that is
verifiable on histopathology so we can
see that it's actually quite a bit more
complex when we look at it from a
cellular level on the far left we can
see
acute interstitial nephritis
demonstrated in this cartoon that was
put together by dr. Gwen pace from our
group and I think she did a very nice
job with this and acute interstitial
nephritis we can see the T cells and
dendritic cells causing inflammation
leading to cellular toxicity the two
cells on the right represent acute
tubular necrosis
this and the downstream the downstream
occurrences from oxidative stress which
we can see are quite complex as well as
cast formation which also can lead to
cellular injury and the question that we
have to ask clinically is well can we
detect this cellular injury before it
actually leads to problems for the
patient so are we able to determine in
advance when a patient has suffered a
cellular injury but before it becomes
more of a functional change and I'll
show you some of these novel biomarkers
some of the newer biomarkers where this
might be the case our traditional
biomarkers such as blood urea nitrogen
and serum creatinine usually start to
elevate after there already is
considerable damage and then finally
when we see things such as protein in
the urine and high blood pressure there
is already quite a bit of damage and now
there's quite a bit of interested in
these kidney biomarkers the predictive
safety testing consortium working group
has started to look at a large number of
these biomarkers and start to think
about them relative to the location of
the nephron and the different types of
injuries that might occur when we think
about ideal biomarkers we think about
biomarkers that will indeed show a
relationship with actual toxicity we
think about biomarkers that can be
identified early before too much
toxicity happens we'd like to see
biomarkers that are specific to kit the
kidney we'd like to see biomarkers that
can show a gradation of injury over time
and then later show recovery from kidney
injury and over time we would like to
know the various limitations of these
and and characterize them finally we
want biomarkers that are easy to obtain
it's not very helpful if we have to give
our patients kidney biopsies in order to
determine if there is kidney injury
now serum creatinine has been one of
most commonly used biomarkers and it's
it's a good marker of injury as well as
function however it is very slow to
react and it's slow to react and differs
based on the amount of baseline injury
that a patient has so based on a
patient's stage of kidney disease these
are the values this is the amount of
time it takes the red the red squares
the amount of time it takes for
creatinine to double and so we see that
it is very difficult for the clinician
to predict what our serum creatinine
czar indeed telling from us telling for
us and you add that with a high inner
passion variability and it makes it very
difficult to create population models
over time we're going to start talking I
think about biomarkers that can help
tell us and help differentiate between
kidney injury and kidney function serum
creatinine and blood urea nitrogen are
good good about telling us about kidney
injury and they also can be good about
telling us about function however we've
already talked about the fact that they
are a little bit slow to react other
other markers such as urine output are
commonly used I think we're going to
start to see some of our newer
biomarkers things such as kidney injury
molecule one cluster and osteopontin and
n gal being used to define early injury
however these are not yet fda-approved
they've been FDA qualified for
preclinical study but they are not yet
FDA approved
there is one FDA approved urinary
biomarker that's temp to IGF bp7 and
that goes by the trade name of neferu
check unfortunately we haven't seen too
many drug studies yet to know how drug
induced kidney injury is detectable with
this biomarker now over time I think
we're going to start to see better
better markers a function as well those
would include better surrogates for
glomerular filtration rate
right now the most commonly used is to
estimate our GFR s with serum creatinine
however we may start to see more use of
cysts aten c which is one of the newer
biomarkers and we may start to see some
of these more research type methods as
they become more and more palatable in
that you can indeed look at a real-time
glomerular filtration rate here's just a
very quick sample from our laboratory
these were rats that receive sinistra
n-- fitzy and they were monitored with
this device to record the clearance of
that synastry this certainly is not
approved for clinical use yet but I do
think over time we will see more and
more clinical products start to reach
the market where our clinicians will be
able to know what a patient's GFR is in
real time by giving a more exogenously
lying on endogenous substances such as
serum creatinine now why are we so
interested in these biomarkers the
reason is that they tend to be very
sensitive and very specific for kidney
injury some of the early preclinical
data with kidney injury molecule one
shows that if you clamp the renal
pedicle on a rat you see a very clear
and clean response from the kidney
injury molecule one as opposed to when
we look at our traditional biomarkers
such as blood urea nitrogen and serum
creatinine now when we start talking
about how this might work its way into
clinical care and the dosing of
vancomycin we can start to think about
all of those different biomarkers and
what they represent in terms of kidney
structures and what might be injured now
the various biomarkers can be specific
for various nephron structures for
instance kidney injury molecule one is
very highly specific for the renal
proximal tubules
and we know that is where vancomycin
causes its damage our group is shown
with immunohistochemistry as well as
urinary biomarkers that kidney injury
molecule one is the best biomarker for
predicting renal injury due solely to
vancomycin in a rat model now this is
still a long way from clinical care but
we do think that in the in the not so
distant future we will be able to
monitor some of these biomarkers and
determine if patients are suffering
renal insults specific to the exact type
of drugs that they are receiving and
hopefully over time we're going to be
able to fold all of this together
there's a field of study that's been
called pharmaco metrics and this field
of study essentially can be distilled
down to what people used to call the
pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic
relationships of a drug pharmacodynamics
is essentially what happens after you
give the drug and that can fall into the
two buckets of efficacy and toxicity and
pharmaco metrics essentially is the math
that describes all of those
relationships together so over time we
would like to start to create
relationships and/or understand the
relationships by which we can measure
drug concentrations control those drug
concentrations and understand the
threshold for both reaching toxicity and
the thresholds for reaching efficacy and
preventing toxicity and this can be done
in our preclinical models by passing the
drug shown in Figure a is simply an lcms
assay we can then create pharmacokinetic
models in panels B and C and fit those
models such that they're specific to the
individual
once we're able to estimate or clearly
measure the exposures for each of those
animals we can then start to think about
how those exposures relate to injury and
some of our initial studies demonstrated
that Kym one cluster and an osteopontin
were the best biomarkers for identifying
vancomycin induced kidney injury and we
can create we can we can fit and find
the mathematic relationships that are
associated with pharmacokinetic
parameters in this case we're looking at
area under the concentration curve the
maximal concentration and the minimum
concentration when moving left to right
we don't need a lot of math to see that
the concentrate on the far left are much
better fit than those are in the middle
and those are on the far right and our
first models we can see that the area
under the concentration curve is what
most clearly describes kidney injury as
defined by kidney injury molecule one in
the rat model now on those previous
slides we saw that it was a little bit
difficult to tease out whether it was
area under the concentration curve or
the maximal concentration that was
actually driving the toxicity so to help
answer this question we decided to
complete a dose fractionation study and
this was done by dr. Sean Abadie Xion
who was with our lab at the time and is
now an assistant professor at the
University of Nebraska you can see in
panel a he was very successful in
creating this fractionation scheme and
fitting his pharmacokinetic model and in
panel B this obviously led to the
maximal concentrations being well
separated that when you give the drug
four times daily with the same daily
total amount you get a lower C max in
that group then when you give it as a
single daily dose now interestingly what
he found was that as we increase the
fractionation and as the sea max went
down for essentially similar a
CAES we got lower kidney injury as
demonstrated and measured by Kim one in
our rat model from there we're able to
fit relationships again so fit some of
these mathematic relationships and look
at dose response curves we can see that
both for AUC and for C max there are
very good curves that are fit and they
correspond with increases in kidney
injury molecule one we also see that as
we look at all of the Kim one in the
furthest panel to the right that third
panel to the right that as the drug was
given in a more fractionated fashion we
also see lower kidney injury so this
suggests that we might be able to get
less kidney injury by giving the drug
more frequently even for the same total
daily dose now the human studies so far
have focused mostly on area under the
concentration curve we now know that
trough is both imprecise for for
determining pharmacokinetic models and
understanding a human's exposure to
vancomycin as well as in the animal
model it is very clearly not the correct
pharmacokinetic parameter for looking at
toxicity there were a number of studies
that have been done that have looked at
how area under the concentration curve
relates with Manko myosin toxicity and
dr. doha al Jeffery was able to look at
this in a meta analysis she found that
the the point at which toxicity the
point at which toxicity was increased
was around an agency of about 650 and
this analysis was limited by the total
number of studies that were done and the
manner in which the data could be
compiled however we did start to see
that even
than the therapeutic range the previous
therapeutic range we were starting to
see that it might be prudent to lower a
UCS for our patients to not incur excess
toxicity a study performed by dr. Tom
ludus the provide study implemented a
desirability outcome analysis and if we
focus on the red bars here those are
what we would consider to be the best
possible outcome and so those red bars
are that the patient survives and the
treatment is a success and they do not
have acute kidney injury we can see that
the red bars are really quite similar
for the two groups that are shown on the
left
that's an AUC between 94 and 387 and an
AUC of 392 to 515
however there appeared to be a pretty
clean break after we got above that that
grouping of 515 and our patients tended
to do less well we started to get more
kidney injury so the pink bars are what
are shown as the patients survived there
was treatment success however there was
acute kidney injury this study and
others are being used to suggest that
the upper limit for au C's should be
somewhere around this range somewhere in
the 515 to around 600 range so these are
not exact numbers at this point but we
are starting to see that there is some
threshold that we will be able to figure
out over time now our group has been
interested in trying to figure out how
all of this links up and the reason is
because in order to enroll a patient
into a clinical trial it costs about
$40,000 to enroll that patient in a
clinical trial and we need many many
patients to be randomized in order to
detect differences so this makes doing
these clinical trials very expensive and
impractical and furthermore oftentimes
the clinical trials that are completed
are not able to focus on important
subgroups for instance what happens to a
patient with diabetes so our group has
been working on linking up what we know
about
this for humans and the outcomes for rat
and we're trying to create a model by
which the rat will predict humans so far
we've had some success and we hope to
present these data at the upcoming Ekman
conference but what we can see is that
the rat model is highly reproducible and
it is simply shifted to the right of
that for the human that is very similar
to allometric scaling the rat requires a
predictable amount more than the human -
cause that nephrotoxicity and that
predictable amount being mathematically
replicatable is important for future
studies ultimately we can put this into
more complex pharmacokinetic models and
really start to figure out what's going
on with biomarkers and those are
biomarkers that we can obtain in in the
box for down there that is within the
urine and we can very carefully
understand the amount that we give our
preclinical models model the
pharmacokinetic exposures and then model
toxicity and where I think this will go
in the very near future is in addition
to measuring injury with things such as
urinary biomarkers I think that we will
be able to look at real-time glomerular
function with methodologies such as that
that I showed you earlier with semestre
now there are brand new guidelines that
are coming out they should probably be
out within the next month or so and
those guidelines are expected to say
that first we should assume that all
Staphylococcus aureus mi C's r1 unless
we very clearly know them to be higher
and that if you're treating
Staphylococcus aureus in a serious
infection and most Staphylococcus aureus
infections are serious that you should
maintain your vancomycin a ucs between
400 and 600 milligrams per liter and I
think we're gonna find that this number
will change a little bit over time and
this is the first that they have set an
area under the concept and an AUC an
area under the concentrate
curved target for vancomycin we will get
more precise over time and I think we
probably will learn that at that upper
range we will see excess toxicity and
perhaps no additional efficacy benefit
but those studies will need to be
completed and then what the clinicians
really want to know is after all of this
is said and done can we be more precise
for our patients so they do not end up
with a bad outcome so they we can get
them to efficacy without getting to
nephrotoxicity and we're able to with
with better mathematical models these
days we were able to create precision
dosing this was a slide that was given
to me by dr. Michael Neely from the
laboratory of applied pharmacokinetics
and bioinformatics and his lab has been
field leaders in generating software
that help us understand ways to
individualize doses for patients now we
can use Bayesian priors that is all the
information that is known about inner
patient variability and intra patient
variability and sparse sampling to best
understand what sort of concentration
profile a patient may obtain with even
sparse sampling and I think we'll start
to see these type of programs make it
into computer systems in the very near
future
you will not need to understand all of
the math behind these computer programs
I don't think I think that in the very
near future we will be able to have
these things available in very graphical
format that is very understandable to
our clinicians that spend rightly so the
vast majority of their time treating
their patients and I think we're going
to start to see that precision dosing
really is a subset of precision medicine
precision medicine has previously been
defined mostly as genomics but precision
dosing really is the
medicine that was occurring for genomics
there is much variability in the doses
and exposures that our patients receive
and we still do not know nearly as much
as we should about how those exposure
response relationships manifest so I
think it's an exciting time for our
clinicians there's a lot of information
coming out and we're very quickly
putting the tools that clinicians need
into their hands in order to control the
exposures of those medications for their
patients I'm always very thankful for
our excellent group a lot of the work
that I showed you today has been
supported by the NIH NIAID and we have
other ongoing studies but it really is
the people that permit all of this work
to be completed so many thanks to the
PhDs and the postdocs in the lab and our
clinical partners at Northwestern and so
that concludes our talk today I really
appreciate the time and the opportunity
to speak with you about how I think that
urinary biomarkers and precision dosing
really are going to change the way that
we're treating patients in the future
thank you so much